we're learning more and more about the
cacophony of corrupt crony capitalists
kleptocratic creeps tough to say that
are the Donald Trump cabinet every day
the latest is Tom Price Congressman Tom
Price Trump's incoming Secretary of
Health and Human Services I told you
before he's wanted to destroy Obamacare
for years and make health care even more
of a capitalistic for-profit endeavor
turns out this also applies to his own
personal finances and the kleptocracy
grows we now know it sounds made up
because it's so insane Tom Price bought
shares of medical device manufacturers
Zimmer biomet in March of 2016 according
to House of Representative records that
BuzzFeed not infowars House of
Representatives records show that he
bought shares of Zimmer biomed days
later Tom Price introduced a bill in the
house that would have directly benefited
Zimmer biomet a big bill called the hip
Act which would have delayed for years a
regulation that would have been bad for
Zimmer biome its finances this would
already be bad enough fat to warrant
investigation into Tom Price arguably if
depending on what that turned up
impeachment of Tom Price possibly
illegal act insider trading who knows
what's on the table but then it gets
even more corrupt the company's
political action committee then
immediately after the introduction of
this bill donated to Tom Price towards
his reelection campaign remember the
Mexican wall just got 10 feet higher the
real phrase should be the swamp just got
10 feet deeper yeah I think it would be
one thing if legislation just came up on
the House floor that I do with being hip
replacements and Tom Price looked at his
financial portfolio right and his list
of campaign contributors and thought
well you know it's my best in my best
interest to support or reject this yes
yeah it'll be we would still be a
violation of ethics law yeah and that
kind of speaks more to the more systemic
corruption that we have going on in this
country or he introduced this
legislation this is not an isolated
incident The Wall Street Journal last
month looked into Tom Price and revealed
that he had traded about 300,000 dollars
worth of shares in the last four years
in health companies while
doing legislation that could impact them
the reaction taught from Tom Price this
is this is rich he didn't buy the shares
a broker did this is deliberately
misleading and deceptive it's not a
blind trust right if a broker buys the
shares for you that says nothing about a
potential conflict of interest it says
nothing at all about quid pro quo what
will Trump's explanation be I have no
idea Oh Tom Price is a savvy businessman
who makes great deals insider trading
doesn't make them corrupt make them
smart if it's true this man should not
only not be Secretary of Health and
Human Services he should be impeached as
a member of Congress he should be banned
from ever serving in politics again he
should be investigated and prosecuted
criminally depending on the outcome of
that administration this is what can I
call it swamp filling middle-class
destroying corruption and it is being
put in charge of people's health you
imagine these trampas Pat think Trump's
going to make America great again for
them the person in charge of health care
is allegedly involved in quid pro quo
corruption and insider trading not in
any industry in the health care industry
yeah I guess now this man is in charge
of repealing and I guess replacing also
Obamacare can't really expect them to be
impartial to this industry hit the now
it all makes sense because he was one of
the few Republicans that actually had a
plan to replace Obamacare it just
happens to be like a the most crony
capitalist vulture capitalist
replacement you could imagine an even
more free market quote solution to it
it's all coming into place now during
the transition period Donald Trump is
add more scandals than President Obama
had during eight years of governing
today's episode is brought to you in
part by blue apron blue apron really is
doing what it can to have a positive
impact on our communities their seafood
is source sustainably under standards
that have been developed in partnership
with the Monterey Bay Aquarium Seafood
Watch the beef is raised humanely
chickens or free-range they're using
regenerative farming practices for the
produce that they use and the best part
for me is reducing food waste we've
talked many times about the amount of
food that is just wasted at different
points in the production and delivery
process and blue apron ships to you the
exact amount of each ingredient that's
required for recipe so you don't end up
throwing anything out I hate throwing
out food and when I cook with blue apron
which I did last week and I'll tell you
about that in a second I don't throw any
food out some of the meals available
this month include spaghetti squash and
marinara with mushrooms and garlic knots
spicy shrimp and Korean rice cakes with
cabbage I made this dish last week I've
never even seen Korean rice cakes before
never mind cooked with them and it was
great I mean I get to try things that I
would ordinarily not think of trying you
can check out this week's entire menu
and get your first 3 meals for free with
free shipping as well by going to blue
apron calm / hackman it will feel good
and it will taste good to create
home-cooked meals with blue apron check
it out at blue apron calm / Pakman
that's PA ke ma n